-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Andy Cohen.
So obviously, New York has a new
mayor but, even more exciting,
a new cast
of New York Housewives.
-Yes, this is a big deal.
-It's a huge deal.
-Wow, I didn't know where
you were going with that.
My God. By the way,
there is a Housewife,
a former Housewife
in the universe
who I found out today has
a major crush on Seth Meyers.
-Really?
-Yes. Yes.
She is a former peach holder
from "The Real Housewives
of Atlanta."
-Okay.
-She is Phaedra Parks.
-Phaedra Parks?
-Yes.
She is an attorney at law
and a mortician.
And she likes you.
-Wow! That is great.
-She could handle
your legal bills.
And she could plan your funeral.
-Yeah.
-Yes. Absolutely.
-I was going to say, if there's
a funeral she needs to plan,
it's my wife's.
-Well, I was going to say that,
but I didn't want to.
-That's really kind.
That's your host at heart.
You left the nicer joke for me.
-I did. I did.
I also -- I was like,
am I going to make a joke
about his wife like that?
It's like, I'm not --
I don't think I'm doing that.
Yes.
-I'm realizing your restraint
was probably the smarter
of the two paths.
-Well, by the way,
not a great week
to make jokes
about people's wives.
-No.
-Yes.
-So, you are no stranger
to slaps.
-Yes.
-In the "Housewife" universe.
-That is true.
-Yeah.
You've seen,
you've observed tempers rising
and someone making the terrible
decision to slap someone else.
-Yes, I have.
-Do you --
-Where are you going with this?
-Do you think this is --
I mean, obviously,
these two people were friends.
Do you think there's a chance,
even after the stage slap --
-That they could come together?
-Yeah.
-Oh, my God, well,
I live in a universe
where Housewives do and say
terrible things to each other.
And then they're like,
"You know what?
I think we're gonna be okay."
-Yeah.
-Yeah, so in my universe, yes.
-I think there is a path out.
-I do, too.
-I think we fix this.
-Yes.
-Now, unfortunately,
we all had to watch it.
-That is true.
-Yeah.
-What's the worst heckling
experience you've ever had?
The very worst, where you
were, like, shaky after?
-I -- My improv partner and I
did the mistake.
We were in Edinburgh
at the Fringe Festival,
and we performed
at a stand-up night,
and so it was
a Scottish audience,
and we tried to do, like,
American improv.
We were asking Scots
late at night for suggestions,
and they were very angry.
-Right.
-And I remember
at the end of the night,
the emcee was naming
all the acts,
and when he said our names,
it was dead silent.
-Wow.
-And then one guy just went,
"[Bleep]"
[ Laughter ]
And it was like --
it was so solitary,
as if they had agreed
ahead of time,
no one will say anything
and then, whatever,
Pat over here will yell,
"[Bleep]"
-Right.
Right.
-So that was probably --
-That was it, yes.
-You've also got --
You've got a "Real Housewives"
not just new here in New York.
-Right.
-But Dubai.
-Dubai. Dubai.
-How'd you pick?
Why Dubai?
-I just watched the first
episode this very day,
as a matter of fact.
It was really exciting.
You know, I think Dubai --
when you deal with a city
that winds up making
Beverly Hills
look, like, pedantic...
-Yeah.
-...it's kind of -- you're like,
"Oh, well,
I'm paying attention here.
So I'm excited for --
It's a totally different --
And I think there are
a lot of people
who have ideas about Dubai that,
you know,
all women are X, Y, or Z.
And this is really going to
blow the lid
off of a lot
of preconceived notions.
-Yeah, that's true.
-So to speak, yeah.
-I'm not even realizing.
I'm like, "Oh, yeah.
I would have a lot
of preconceived notions."
And then how much of it --
Obviously, you pick a place,
and that's a huge part of it.
-Right.
-Having done all these seasons,
how quickly do you realize
you've nailed it with the cast?
That you've gotten the right
people to be engaging?
-I mean, typically we don't
launch until we have a cast
that we feel like
is a great cast and we love.
But, I mean, usually,
you can tell pretty quickly.
I mean, they make you laugh.
I mean, these women
are superstars.
It's why we're still going
16 years later.
And the New York thing,
it's super exciting.
We announced a couple weeks ago,
we are recasting "The Real
Housewives of New York City"
from the ground up.
-Yeah.
-And what an exciting
thing to do,
because there are so many
stories to be told in New York
and so many that
we haven't told yet.
-Is there a higher standard
when you're doing New York?
Like, do you feel
a little bit more anxiety
about trying to do that again?
-I mean,
we just want to find stars.
We just want
to find great people.
-That's exciting.
-Yeah. Yes.
-And they must, at this point --
the other nice thing is
you've had this go on so long,
this franchise, people must be
so excited to be a part of it.
-They are.
-Yeah.
-There are two types of people.
People who want to be
on the "Housewives"
and people who don't, yes.
We are looking for the ones
who want to appear.
-They're like,
"I'll be on your show,
but I'd like to keep my private
life and my work life separate."
-Yeah.
Oh, yeah, yeah, exactly. Great!
-Thank you so much
for being here.
-Thanks, man.
Great to see you.
-Guys, that's Andy Cohen.
"Watch What Happens Live
with Andy Cohen"
airs Sunday through
Thursday nights on Bravo.